hi welcome to vegas thank you very much
good to see you you can't drink you
can't gamble you can't do anything here
we listen to some great music we sure
are how you been uh i've been amazing
yeah finished filming not too long ago
it's been good life's good we'll talk
all about it how excited are you to be
here at the iheart radio music festival
i'm stoked i think the last time i was
here was in maybe 2019 i would say um so
now that music's back and
i mean so many amazing performers
tonight uh i can't wait to see khalid
and really irish and coldplay and i
could keep going so i'm just stoked to
be here i did hear no eye contact with
coldplay though just fyi seriously
where'd it go no
i know i'm sorry if i ruined anything
for you but
i won't hold it against you okay so what
are you you're presenting tonight right
uh i presented at the daytime stage hell
see they got you all over the place i'm
back here i can't see anything it's
hectic how was the energy out there in
vegas
so amazing um when olivia rodrigo came
out it was like i can't even explain you
like the energy it was so
electrifying like it was it and it was
our first concert so she killed it so
proud of her i love it now you just
mentioned you finished filming
how did it go shazam too yeah it went
really well yeah i can't wait for people
to see what's in store for the second
movie because it's something special i
know everything is lock and key with
these types of films but what can you
tease um what can i tease let's see here
um
i'm really excited for everyone to see
the additional characters
um
helen mirren obviously and rachel zigler
who is snow white which is amazing so
yeah get ready because it's going to be
a fun ride okay how was working with
helen mirren
oh
she's the sweetest like just amazing i
can't even i can't say too much because
i can't go into details
i'll get too excited so yeah leave it at
that amazing okay so you got to work
with all of these additional characters
but you had the og mr zachary levi with
you how great was it to reunite with
zach so good uh zack zack's the homie uh
you know we all get along really well
zach jack and i were
like family you know and um i can't wait
for everyone to see this chemistry that
we have on screen um with jack and i
because i have a lot more scenes with
him so
you guys really are a family i mean i
was just on zach's instagram the other
day and he calls you his little brother
and what is
what do you guys do to occupy the time
when you weren't filming what kind of
time did you spend together
we go to soccer games we we do all these
fun excursions together
and i was going back and forth a lot
while i was out there but um yeah we do
a lot of fun stuff what is what advice
has he given you or just kind of
perspectives about growing up in
this spotlight it's something that he
has navigated being a little bit older
and being kind of a mentor to you has he
given you some lessons sat you down at
all no definitely yeah uh
you know it's i think the most important
thing for us is never taking anything
for granted you know because we're young
um and we're in a position in our life
that you know we get to do amazing
things and we get to make movies and you
know a lot of people would die for this
so um yeah just don't take things for
granted and live in the moment and just
have fun you know does he tell you to be
responsible with your money
yeah yeah he's a good big brother he's a
good mentor he loves us he wants us to
do well
same for him
now i gotta ask you i saw some videos
recently that you were taking your
driver's test
how'd that go did you pass so i i did
like a driving course um i didn't finish
the course yet i still have like two
more driving lessons but it's getting
there okay we're in it almost there it's
progress now do you have a car already
so when you get your license you're
ready to literally go i don't think i'll
i don't think i'm gonna get a car right
out of the gate but i am planning on
what i'm gonna get what is it whether
it's three years from now i don't know
how long it's gonna be because i keep
postponing it uh so i don't know what do
you want though what's on the bucket
list for a car
i don't know i mean i think the
lamborghini euros is pretty cool
um
maybe uh ford bronco
would be on the list yeah it's a little
bit more
humble
maybe some cool like
old
mustang something sick some old school
fashion like
old school car you need something too
that this is why i do support the lambo
because then you can have like the top
down blasting your music that's right
and that's a vibe
that's like that's the way to go
speaking of do we have new music we do
have new music uh i actually was just in
la recording new music so it's it's
coming i'm excited the infamous tease
it's coming it's coming yeah i know hey
i'm trying to get it right i'm trying to
get it perfect because i don't want to
just put something out that
you know it's just mediocre yeah they
say good things take time that's right
amen
[Music]
you